okay so you and i know each other we've
known each other over many years
um in similar circles and circumstances
we've really spoken to each other like
two women two humans
and
what i didn't know
was that you were staying at anna
wintour's house
and
that she was a source of
consistent check-ins
as well as
encouragement for this is this true
absolutely true you know she is the book
was her idea and um
and to have a friend like anna she
really was the first person who called
me
right after the 2016 election and you
know when half the country was in
mourning
uh over that loss and i was so
devastated i was so shattered and she
called me and said we're going to dinner
and at dinner she said i know what you
should do next you should write your
story it's a good story and you should
write it and i wasn't convinced that i
would i went and then talked to hillary
a couple of days later she said i should
do it it took some convincing for me to
do it but i did and i'm glad i did and
it's been incredible therapy and being
out in the world
there's something so liberating and
empowering about it i've really enjoyed
it i'm so excited to know that like anna
wintour
you know was there to nurture you
um and she's not the warmest creature
you know so i love hearing that the
you know this very stoic woman
was
what you needed
when she was there for you well she
actually gave me the gift of friendship
at a time when i really needed it it was
in the midst of one of my very difficult
periods in my marriage and there was a
public
demand
that i'd be fired
because i had chosen to stay with my
husband
who had been unfaithful to me and i at
that moment had chosen to stay with him
and i remember we were at this dinner
and all the headlines were is hillary
gonna fire huma
and in the middle of this dinner she
walks over to me as you know the cameras
are following and says would you like to
have lunch sometime
and really ever since that moment
you know pushed me all the time was
always there if i needed something but
pushed me to make decisions to stay true
to myself to not listen to my detractors
and i'm really great i had that with
hillary and i've had that with anna and
i'm just privileged to have two women
like that in my life all right we're
talking about really strong women huge
figures here
and
hillary
you know hrc as you call her throughout
the book and she famously made a life
choice a political decision a personal
decision and we're putting ourselves out
there so make no mistake we've chosen
public life yes
we're not naive about that we've made a
conscious choice yes
and is it true that you would go and
talk to her each time
uh a transgression as you call it
throughout the book with anthony
you would go into her office a woman who
probably there's no one who could
understand more
living in the life being a huge
political figure
what were those conversations i think
one of the greatest gifts walking into
the white house at 21
during the clinton administration i
joined this club it's a club that comes
with lifetime membership and it's club
called hillary land and the thing that's
amazing about being in this environment
is that it was a workspace where you
walked in and you felt like you were
respected and your work was valued and
everyone took responsibility for things
as a community it was a very much a
sense of support so we i would say you
know that it was a place where as women
climbed up the ladders of success they
did not step on the fingers of the women
below them but reached the lowest and
pulled the rest of us up too so it was
an environment where i was like how do
we do this job better or you did a great
job on that speech how's your mother
doing you should go talk to my allergist
happy birthday
and hillary land was all of those things
because hillary clinton is all of those
things and so to be part of that
community i think did help me throughout
obviously the highs in my life and
certainly the lows in my life and every
time i did have a personal problem and
it wasn't just in my relationship just
generally i'm not feeling well my mom is
not doing well
she always approached these
conversations as a friend first and as a
boss second
and the advice she always gave me was
do what is right i'm here
you do what is right for you it was
never judgmental and whatever you choose
to do
i'm gonna support you
[Music]
you